CARAVAN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
YOU HAVE SEEN THESE PHOTOS.
WELL, THE CURRENT SITUATION AT
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF HAND.
THAT CARAVAN OF CENTRAL
AMERICAN MIGRANTS THAT STARTED
DOWN TO ABOUT 200 PEOPLE OR SO,
AND MANY OF THEM ARE CAMPED
OUT AT JUST A STONE'S THROW
FROM THE U.S. CUSTOMS CHECK
POINT.
NOW, AS WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING,
THE ALIENS ARE BEING COACHED
IN SOME CASES, BY AMERICAN
LAWYERS, TRAVELING TO THE
CARAVAN, AND TELLING THEM HOW
TO QUALIFY FOR ASYLUM.
THIS UNDOUBTEDLY INFURIATES
MANY OF YOU, WHO WOULD ALSO
LOVE FREE LEGAL ADVICE.
WOULDN'T THAT BE NICE?
THE PRESIDENT AS WELL IS
TOTALLY FED UP.
HE TWEETED THIS WEEK THE
MIGRANT CARAVAN THAT IS OPENLY
DEFYING OUR BORDER SHOWS HOW
WEAK AND INEFFECTIVE U.S.
IMMIGRATION LAWS ARE.